the dark has a life of its own
Kirk Douglas said that in the bad and
the beautiful one of the best movies
about movies ever made we're celebrating
and honoring Kirk Douglas tonight
because he's done nearly everything on
film he's directed he's produced and in
the process
he's helped to hammer the blacklist to
pieces and of course most memorably and
most lastingly he's acted he's done that
the way he does everything with grace
and courage
whether he's dealing with a character on
screen or with the all-too-real effects
of a recent stroke courage remains Kirk
Douglas his personal and professional
hallmark most stars of his stature are
shaped out of mythic clay Kirk Douglas
never chose that he doesn't have a
single character that makes him unique
instead he has a singular honesty a
drive to be inimitable that's what
animates all his roles from Spartacus to
Vincent van Gogh there's a single thread
drawing all his characters together and
it's called conscience every person he
ever played had one and because Kirk
Douglas never made his characters simple
no good guys or bad guys he shaded
heroics with self-doubt and shaped his
villainy with compassion his characters
weren't bigger than life they were life
reconverted something we all could
identify with something that would touch
us out there in the dark something that
gave the dark a life and a light of its
own
many who gentlemen Kirk Douglas
thank you thank you I see my four sons
they are proud of the old man
and I am proud to proud to be a part of
Hollywood for 50 years but this is for
my wife and I love you
and unite I love all of you and I thank
all of you for pretty wonderful years
thank you thank you
you